quantum particles such as electrons
carry a value of spin an intrinsic form
of angular momentum
particles can either have the value of
spin-up or spin-down
the name comes from an analogy that the
particle is spinning about its axis like
a planet but this comparison is wrong
and misleading the very notion that
electrons and protons are solid objects
that can rotate in space is difficult to
sustain given what we know about the
rules of quantum mechanics
the notion of stem came about after an
experiment in which a beam of electrons
were fed through a device which is able
to show the orientation of magnets if
you had placed a magnet in the device
and the North Pole of the magnet was
pointing up the magnet would be
deflected upwards by an amount
corresponding to how close to straight
up and down a head beam when electrons
went through the device
they were also deflected as if they were
tiny magnets but only to two locations
up or down by a certain distance those
that went up were said to have spin up
and those that went down who said to
have spin down
spen is an essential property
influencing the ordering of electrons
and nuclei in atoms many if not most
physical processes ranging from the
smallest nucleus scales to the largest
Astrophysical distances depend greatly
on interactions of subatomic particles
and the spins of those particles